99
of people that say stuff like that are
not willing to do what it takes to make
their dreams come true the marines have
a saying everybody wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die
and that's just real at the center of
bringing any dream into fruition is
self-discipline
you know some something as simple as
food and eating it it's not about your
your body as much as it is about your
mind it's getting command of your mind
to be able to choose actions that are in
your own best interest every day
we are choosing [ __ ] that's not in our
own best interest right so if the world
is attacking you and the world wants to
fight you and the world's trying to hold
you down so you won't kick yourself in
the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success
the thing about self-discipline is that
it is necessary for everything you do in
your life you have to be
self-disciplined if discipline comes
from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist it's wild
because i see trainers and they're in
the gym with people and
you know
the guy or girl that they're working out
hates their workout hates it because the
discipline is coming from somewhere else
you it's something that you dread every
time you go in you don't really want to
do it it's like uh but oh no my
trainer's here he's about to you know
beat me up and make me feel crazy well
the truth is every trainer
should work his way out of your life
anybody who's working you out your
teachers your trainers your people they
have to train you
to get out of your life so you can go
ahead do your own workout do your own
thing practice self-discipline
[Music]
i always wanted to win the world cup
that was the reason i started and as the
time went by
i started enjoying cricket and i started
realizing the challenges of cricket
and my coach was instrumental along with
my brother
to to my elder brother rajiv
to make me realize
the the importance of
leading a disciplined life a focused
life
and
to to to
make me push harder they found reasons
and and even
towards the end of my career i followed
that formula
i've never met a person who was not
successful
that didn't have a great amount of
self-discipline within their life
self-discipline and being able to
perform and being able to keep your life
on schedule and being able to keep
commitments and promises and meet
deadlines
is essential to success
of none of us
none of us can afford to have a life
that is controlled by someone else or a
life that is basically controlled by our
emotions
i learned many years ago that there are
two kinds of people there's the type of
person who says i'm gonna wait till i
feel like it before i do it and then
there's a person who says i've got to do
it so that i feel like it
one will never get anything done because
they're still waiting to feel the moment
to move and the other person says no i
need to move and then i will begin to
feel the movement sauna self-discipline
is essential in your life and in my life
if we're going to get things done
it's real simple if you don't work out
you don't get you don't get a muscle
right so i always tell people this is
there's a daily practice like priming if
you don't do that if you get up and you
just have no discipline whatsoever you
get no value of anything your diets
don't work when you don't do them
exercise doesn't work when you don't do
them but most of people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because i went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life i i work out i train my mind i
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else i'm not here to become
somebody's guru i'm not here to give
them a gift i'm here them to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work has
been one of the things that i think you
should always come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up so
that i'm practicing what i call simple
discipline simple discipline is nothing
more than making and keeping simple
promises to yourself repeating it every
day the way that you start to change the
big things is to change the small things
make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so how do
you build simple discipline here are
some core skills that i do every morning
that have helped me number one
i do not sleep with the phone
number two
when the alarm goes off on my phone it's
not near me so i have to get my ass out
of bed you keep those small simple
promises to yourself and you'll start to
build the muscle of simple discipline
and you can start to do it in other
areas of your life
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here